What does it mean when you have an increase in bilirubin?
So, bilirubin is a, shows a function of your liver, really.
So, bilirubin is, when you get your bilirubin measured in your blood,
if you could have a total bilirubin or you could have an indirect bilirubin.
So, you're, typically, your total bilirubin is composed of, what's called your indirect bilirubin.
Your indirect bilirubin is also called your un-pagigated bilirubin.
And that circulates in your blood on the way to the liver.
And then you have direct or conjugated bilirubin.
And that is, when your liver makes the bilirubin water soluble to be deposited in the bile,
to be then go through the bile duct in the gallbladder and in the, in the small intestine.
Remember, your bile is what brings all the toxins from your liver down into your small intestine as well.
That your bile also contains lipase to help break down fats.
So, but bilirubin is the breakdown of hemoglobin.
So, when you have an increased bilirubin, it can be because you have a breakdown in hemoglobin.
So, you can have a breakdown in the blood disorder where you have what's called hemolysis,
where you have a breakdown in red blood cells in the blood.
That's less common.
Most of the time when you see an increase in bilirubin, it's because of a blockage of the bile duct.
So, remember, your bilirubin will ultimately go through the liver and become made water soluble in the liver
and then go through in the bile to the small intestine.
That is the most common, especially for a person who has cancer,
when a person has increased bilirubin, you're concerned with a blocked bile duct.
Now, you can have a blocked bile duct for multiple reasons.
With a, with a diagnosed cancer, you're concerned with metastasis to the liver
and then a space-occupied lesion pinching the bile duct.
There's other possible reasons for a blocked bile duct.
But that's what the biggest thing you'd be concerned with having a current cancer diagnosis is a blocked bile duct.